this is a lot of my favorite bad movies
uh this is Dungeons & Dragons with
Jeremy Irons and it's just beautiful
uh this is one of the few movies this
was during the phase when it was like
late high school early college where we
kind of got into watching bad movies I
think like Mystery Science Theater kind
of rubbed off on us it's like and when
Jesse one this one's just amazing this
one is a work of art of cheese it's so
phenomenal uh and I think as ever we're
we're watching this and this is the
first time actually uh like I say this
is like early calyx it's like you know
early 2000s and this is the first time I
was actually like let's try and do a
Mystery Science Theater because there
was so much and it was so easy and we
started to and then we got boring yeah
it was like two of us and your
ex-girlfriend yeah FBI who also loved
watching bad movies introduced us to
except really good one simple primer
view in the future uh but I know which
one yeah you know talking about that
that's gonna be fun happy Valentine's
Day but what what its gonna be is or not
what its gonna be uh well what it was is
that we're watching we start making
notes that we kind of got bored it's
like new you know we got maybe like ten
minutes into the film or just saying hey
Esther something else uh but then a lot
of those jokes made it back into when we
actually did the review so it was kind
of like preparation for it actually yeah
it was really surreal to do that uh
myself like oh and a Smith that's not
really relevant anymore yeah the first
time we did it he was just like a fun we
were doing it as a hobby it was weird to
do it again professional yeah right um
yeah so I I don't think any of us still
have been a few years we'd be doing it
professionally so it was weird to look
back and I'd be like yeah but that was
one I kept saying to myself one of these
days I'm gonna get to this one because
this movie is so much fun and I guess we
should I never really play Dungeons &
Dragons I've never been to what-have-you
I had friends who did Dean oh we both
have friends I am clean if any I've seen
a few games I've never played it myself
it's something where if you do find and
I
you don't like it oh you never person
why don't you give us I watch it I have
no problem sure thing I think I kept my
hands and Dragons is cool I have no
problem like I have no problem with the
idea the movie on the other hand we know
and from what I see I mean it looks like
this very kind of creative outlay it's
like it's a game but it also has like
you know you can sort of create your own
characters and where it goes and stuff
like that so it's a neat idea it's just
not my thing
um but we so we didn't really know that
much going into Dungeons and Dragons in
the movie
we thought maybe it'll explain a little
bit it clearly didn't Dungeon Dungeons
and Dragons is so huge I mean that it's
been around for so many decades and
there's so many different campaigns and
stuff it's really there's no real
comparison you can't say it's like Lord
of the Rings I mean obviously knows it's
our mid tones playing yeah yeah it just
is so massive it's like what it's like
doing a Doctor Who movie but what which
Doctor Who are you even doing which
character are you picking where's the
time I just it's like been going on for
so long that you know you would have to
just sort of pick one so it's I don't
know if it even helps to know Dungeons
and Dragons to try to watch this movie
yeah nobody else at all I I don't think
it doesn't add anything if if anything
it probably takes away if you do know
anything about what you do know I get
you just like what the fuck is it uh cuz
I heard uh a little bit of a commentary
which I did listen to a little bit Oh
because I just had to know I had to know
what they thought of this movie and they
they seemed okay with it fine with it um
and uh yeah there's at some point like
that weird one I snake Medusa head thing
that's in there for like a second okay
here we got that in there like I guess
that's a Dungeons & Dragons thing or
something but I'm sure there's creatures
and stuff yeah aside of that not much
definitely not I'm not sure that the
original campaigns had Wayans brothers
in it um I don't I don't remember the
mythical Wayans that you encountered
that you have to roll against
I won't be a very terrifying enemy maybe
there was a version my friends in there
I I don't have a but uh but you know
it's it so does not suck you into this
world and I think this was the point
where we started to realize because this
is kind of during the bay
computer-generated explosion everything
with CG then unlike now but you know
certainly where was everywhere it's look
at all the cool stuff we can now do it
this is at the point where cuz the
trailer at the time even though Jeremy
Irons with batch insane it was kind of
okay this might be a little corny but
this might be fun this my cuz look how
visually interesting it is and this is
at the point where visually interesting
was becoming the trailer the trailer did
a great job of disguising how bad it was
yeah the effects did not look as bad in
my memory in the trailer than what we
ended up seeing on screen I remember the
three om doesn't show more the cool
castles and something kind of
interesting
they showed uh what's-her-name American
Beauty on a dragon like in this armor
looking around and it's like what the
catechol that was my favorite drag that
was my favorite throwaway line from the
reviews Joe and holder no Joan of Lark
oh yeah
and so it like but they seem like the
weigh-ins in there and said it's like
okay well this is one on my stimulus now
my the other those I mean okay that
wanes in there but you know maybe middle
or something kind of fun catch easy but
is it from sliders and uh I have been
nice to have John rhys-davies as the
dwarf and I'm not convinced we try to do
it you want know what the sad thing is
whenever I remember this movie I put
John Rizzo in there do I forgetting he's
not in the movie as the dwarf I just
assume it's in there's some sort of
horrible dwarf prejudice that is alive
and well either in films or just with us
because I just always think of John
rhys-davies and that's just kind of ER
I think I think everybody dollars I
think the other thing is that is the
dude from sliders right you know if not
it sure looks like him I
I always cuz like I always kept watching
this Leonie so I don't think it is it
uh-oh who is that guy then I don't know
oh my god like I know oh we should just
pause it and come back yeah what no yes
no I want to find out who this is
member comments would come out what joke
were you gonna make anyway I won't know
I was just gonna say this film always
for some reason riding me of sliders cuz
I thought the guy in it look like the
guy from sliders and John rhys-davies
was also a slider yeah that show that
also makes me and now like the entire
need to give a damn things get it
together
how dare you it I'm just like I said I
think I thought I don't I'm not up on my
early two-thousands like naive ease this
is late 90s right ya know then but does
have the time warp guy who is also from
Dark City and affection Airy pointlessly
actually this cameo oh yeah refreshed to
leave this yeah um this get in to end
Tom Baker yeah that's right that's okay
ah dr. Holmes we wouldn't fool sir no
that was good because I don't watch
Doctor Who and you saw those Tom Baker
like you saw the radius like you better
fucking put a doctor who joking there
they crucify you know I firmly forgotten
he was in it and then when I saw him I
was like like Rick Lee I forgot he was
in yes I know and that's what the Jim is
he willing them we just getting wasted
role um yeah okay okay we're talking all
this stuff about about this movie and
it's not a good movie but it's so
beautifully not good and we're just
overlooking the best part which is
Jeremy Irons clearly now giving I was it
I was gonna say the guy with the Smurfs
blood-stained lips but he's pretty good
too
do not watch Rio and yeah Jeremy Irons I
don't know what he's doing in this movie
but it's phenomenal young man yeah my
tiger I think I know what he is doing
and it this is why it creeps me out
he's making every single thing sexual
the most innocuous things he could be
sitting there just watching a battle I
don't know he's looking at somehow and
somehow these orgasms I and when he
comes up behind that guy yeah yeah it's
like your zi guys
so face dude
it's a little bit it's I'm telling you
man
this is was totally a time where you
know he's like you know I get a feel
like he came into auditions and he saw
that like the directors clearly were not
going to direct him maybe you're iben or
maybe they just told him gold batshit
insane
I don't know cuz I'm a commentary like
he's so good he's so good matches exact
what you're looking for so but you just
know he's like I am going to have fun
with this is going to be I am sure I
don't exactly what happened he took one
look at the sets one look at the fact
that is a Wayans brother in this movie
one look at you know the props and the
other actors that I send out today yeah
and no and he worries just like oh it's
one of those movies I need to give a
shit like I think I worry this star
looks subtle I think he figured it out
right away that this was gonna suck and
he's like why why should I bother trying
to give a Shakespearean performance what
I can do whatever I want here I this was
vacation for him it's like what we were
talking about in the Jupiter ascending
review this is British actors vacation
yeah nice to star in a crappy American
summer blockbusters I don't know what it
is but they just they are 9 out of 10 so
good at their craft I think there is a
part of them that's just like you know
what I'm I know I'm good and I have all
this crap did all this focus and
everything I I just wanna I just wanna
go crazy cuz overacting a big shot me
saying this overacting is a lot of what
to do it is so much fun to do and you
can just go so big and so great you can
make the big goofy faces and is just so
enjoyable and so many of these British
actors you know they have to be good and
they make a whole career out of it but
then they're just you know I just want
to something really silly really stupid
just go totally high hey Tim Curley uh
what's his face for my twilight era but
no famine there no Michael she Michael
she
what was it in one of the late-night
interviews he went on and they were
joking about that and he said oh you
should have seen the ones they didn't
the clips they didn't you yes I did you
my mom better
I can imagine Jeremy Irons saying that
about dungeons and dragons I can see him
saying the guy oh I want bigger island
dang I have no idea no idea what I
really did um I could just I could just
totally see him doing that um yeah
that's why it's so great because he
knows I'm not convinced some people in
this movie know you know that they just
have the dead look in their eyes like
Thora Birch like she did she has been
today she just has the dead look in her
eyes of like wow like really American
Beauty to this I'm like I'm firing my
agent but like he he he knows in the
other way that this is gonna be crap and
it's gonna be amazing
and it's gonna be I'm gonna do whatever
the hell I want and other people don't
know I think they're trying to take it
seriously so it's fun to see this mix of
like actors who completely know this is
gonna tank and don't care and how they
react to it with on the one hand you got
the raw birch with dead sad fish eyes
and it's got like the Schumacher Batman
movies which one knows there yeah this
is gonna be stupid and which one is
trying to take it seriously exactly um
and uh and it's just so much fun it's so
much fun uh it's just lies like what
what even was the plot is down at its
edge the mages and the Phoebe ins and
there's a class warfare and
something-something dragons and then
this long thing in the middle where
there's like this Indiana Jones where
there's a Lost Ark thing where they have
to go through a maze and I remember uh
what you know one of my favorite it's
all pieced together from other fantasies
and cuz I felt like there was like a
village to like every single thing
reminded me of something else and what
blows me away
what blows me away is this was a new
line cinema film released not too far
apart I forget which came across too
long from Lord of the Rings and I'm like
so sad that mean
that while they were filming Dungeons
and Dragons somewhere else Peter Jackson
was filming fellowship do you know what
this movie is this movie is the leftover
acetate so it's moving into leftover CG
and makeup from the more the Rings
movies and say you know we're going to
travel so we got this stuff go make a
budget for Dragons movie is not funny it
is just like this giant ripoff of like
John Williams is like I swear to God
when the bad guys marching it's like the
Imperial margin at one of my favorite
movie memories honestly connects with
this film as when we first sat down to
watch it and we're just seeing so much
bad shit craziness thrown at us and at
some point you just lost it and I think
I see a less eager cow and something too
but if we were watching this and it's
the scene where it was legal yes the the
woman was climbing down the ladders the
librarian and and the whatever the
wizard is they're trying to figure out
something or other and it's like you
know help me out with this and she just
says oh I just get a feeling there's
more to life than putting away books and
then it was glanced over and sigh it was
such a Disney Princess throwaway line yo
and you just burst out laughing and
paused it I was like it was a dump like
I was like whatever what what if you
were just laughing so hard I want you to
sit just on that line it was like really
oh yeah there's just declared the
stupidest thing I'm like for the longest
time until we really delve into some of
the films we had to watch for the ends
yeah I literally listed as the worst
film I've ever seen yeah oh but but it
was like the run yeah a sense then sense
and a couple things have happened one
I've seen how really boring and awful
films can get or just plain ugly like
Garbage Pail yeah now it or to the point
that now I look at this film and I'm
like this film is so hilariously bad
like the room it's like watching you
have your dad acted yeah yeah that I
actually enjoy it way more now than I
ever did like even the the first time we
saw it I would have said it's literally
the worst of all I know something this
funny can't be the worst film ever made
so there are way worse things but yeah
it but it's just such a great moment cuz
it was so remember I remember
what ten minutes is something like that
it's like we just had to glare like you
know just mark it worked I mean just
beautifully words it's so enjoyably
worst and then it bursts out singing I
want much more than this provincial
light yeah Nick it was just like we're
throwing every old has-been cliche in
here I mean even like the Disney
Princess stuff uh you know there's been
done a million times that even Disney
Princesses now are like oh that's so
pass that's so has been oh I still
think the the funniest moment for me the
the greatest moment is because of how
desperately they try to get you to take
it seriously is when Marlon Wayans does
yeah no I'm a they hold I'm like look
what happened guys uh I am and could not
stop laughing I still was snickering
throughout the rest of them because I
would think back to him dying and just
go like it is it literally was the
funniest death scene I had ever seen
until Dhabi in deathly hallows part
because that was another great moment in
my life where and I I thought I was
gonna get kicked out of the cinema cuz
like you know nice all this long nose
Pinocchio no no I feel bad for small
children who around me cuz I'm like
listen I understand you're a kid and
you're taking this serious and and then
they're there but for the rest of us is
also known for the rest of the adults in
the room it was one the most hilarious a
look oh man a shave master and like it
just I burst away because I could just
imagine Daniel Radcliff there with a
Dobby puppet or some puppets supposed to
enjoy a day yeah I'm supposed to
represent Dobby like acting against this
thing thinking my god I'm gonna have to
do something after the series to get my
dignity back it's one of the few times
where it's like the effects but the
effects were actually really good in
that see that it actually heard it
because dobby's designed is so awful
it's an awful design and we just see it
looks really realistic why this little
Pinocchio pointy nose don't make me try
to feel sorry for Dobby
I you know like can you imagine if they
tried to do with death scene with Jar
Jar Binks like that ya know that's
exactly I mean I would love it cuz I
would just laugh my ass off but it was
the same kind of like oh now I have to
feel sorry for marlon wayans I'm like oh
the sacrifice like I couldn't do it I
was just laughing the whole way through
no you know what that's uh we're just
gonna elevate everybody here while we're
doing it but I'll get get somebody back
to me but in the Black Cauldron I don't
think I'm giving anything really away
here but the the Wilford Brimley I mean
let me pop it let me just interrupt you
for one second I want to make this clear
I'm not talking about the book Dobby I'm
talking about the film version of death
Oh people still have your head me no
likey the film version of Dobby I don't
like I'm just little imp
no but for me that was done first Black
Cauldron with sure little look wish that
collar man that little gray area album
and stop and they try to make us really
feel something for him to and I'm just
like fuckin really again make us try to
feel something for you know the term
super house and blah blah plan of like
fucking really we're supposed to shed a
tear for this piece of shit
they're like the monster the most
annoying thing ever no that's pretty
Dobby other months but yeah it's one of
those things where it's like this film
it's just a treasure it's a treasure of
bad it really is in my opinion kind of
the room Oh Mike knows it so
consistently and enjoyably bad in some a
unique way Mike Nelson wrote a great
book called Mike Nelson's movie mega
cheese and that is the best way I'm a
human
he may have reviewed it in there and we
had a lot of bad ones like twister and
Independence Day and just goofy goofy
sort of movies um but that is the best
way to describe this film is it is movie
mega cheese and if you like yummy
delicious movie mega cheese like this is
actually film I'd recommend you watch
yeah no I it is just only recommending
spectacularly bad on a hilarious scale
that it seems a little bit of respect
yeah this is one of those I could not
because a lot of times I'm nostalgic reg
like we could really like a bad movie
but I have to look angry and stuff but
with this one like I can't do it it just
brings me too much pleasure I have to
talk about how enjoyable this film is
and it really is it is just
such an enjoyable film um sister don't
know what else we can really say about
it I think you can come to your own
conclusion about it um so uh nothing
else to say but